when you don't have a fraction but you
have a square root do you remember this
is example for do remember this guy this
guy so we have some rules again for what
values i can put in there yeah and what
values I can't hear I want the
denominator to be anything but zero
anything 20 what do I want about this
what I want X to be fun enough um what's
the square root of 00 have a square
bridge it's the number that i multiplied
by itself to get 0 the answer is 0 so 0
0 actually even though here it's not
okay over here he is ok I'm zeros ok
once ok choose ok please ok what numbers
aren't ok what numbers kind of put in
there it's negatives isn't it right as
the second you go- like negative 1
negative 3 you're in trouble you can pop
it into your calculator and will vary
dutifully tell you that error right we
kind of deal with square roots of
negative numbers at least not for now so
all i need to say is if negative numbers
are the ones that break the function
that I can't put it then what numbers
can I put it just everything above zero
and including zero silence and it's
right do you notice that that's just
very slightly different from saying
positive values because 0 is not
positive it's not maybe neither it's
been my phone off ok so there you go
that's what I've got there and then I
think the last example we did last time
was this it was a fun ok now remembering
that what I want underneath the square
root I want to be greater than or equal
to 0 yes so what I have under the square
root is five take away x greater than or
equal to 0 and then we just have to
solve this thing how do I solve
inequalities a bit sneakier than
equations so I want to give me
suggestion for my first step might be ok
yeah I've got a positive 5 here don't
really want it there so i'll subtract
five from both sides that leaves me
this okay I've got a negative x there I
don't really want any of that so what do
I do i can divide or multiply and not
doing the same thing discuss yeah i'll
multiply by negative 1 that'll make x
over here and positive 5 here but you
have to be careful the inequality it
switches around right now why does it
suit your round anyways just like that
just random arbitrary best teacher is
trying to add more rooms to make things
hard why does it do that okay okay we've
changed the sign but why is changing the
sign change the direction like if I say
this if I say of minus x equals 4 right
i can multiply this equation by negative
1 just like I did here and there's no
problems like I don't have to worry
about any sign of direction or whatever
so why do I have to worry about it here
with an inequality did you have a shot
good good good so this is half the
answer in inequality right you've
literally got two things that are
exactly the same so you do anything to
the left and right hand side and they're
meant to be the same thing so it should
be fine but here the point of an
inequality like if I say things are not
equal okay the point is that they're not
the same so you can't treat them as
identical which is what happens over
here let's give it a quick example right
I know 2 is less than three at least
last I checked right calculator 21 but
but if i multiply both sides by negative
1 or any negative number if i have
negative 2 and negative 3 over here is
negative 2 still less than negative 3
and the answer is no in fact it's bigger
right because this is more negative so
you can see clearly and example makes it
really obvious why the inequalities
gotta sit around and the whole point is
just this was mentioned two and three of
the same number so negative 2 and
negative also up the same okay so
there's the domain that's what we looked
at last time now how are we going to
interpret range will do it for the same
set of questions as you'll see these are
going to come
pretty quickly right range means one of
the Y values we can get out what can we
get out of this right you put in as many
exhale use as you want and what kinds of
upwards will you get okay now when you
have a look at this graph here 1 over X
just like horizontally right for the
domain when you look vertically up and
down there's still a single spot where
you can't get why boat no matter what
excited put in you'll never get a Wi-Fi
here what's the spot it's y equals 0 you
see you now put in another color and if
you have another color as well maybe you
want to indicate it on the same graph so
you can see everything on that to put in
is going to be talking about rain now y
equals 0 is off limits on that graph off
limits on that graph so it's outside the
domain sorry outside the range right
it's not part of it how would I state
the range of this I can I can be I'll
try and do it in like small to big
that's usually the way we do things just
like way from small to be so I can be
below y equals 0 that's why is this a 0
or I can be a bug right which is what
I'm when I just mentioned y is greater
than 0 below above just a lot on the
line okay yeah with this guy interesting
reading I've moved to the left a bit of
other way you see I'm negative a half
instead of 0 but I've moved left and
right nothing is changed up or down
nothing has changed up or down so you
can see I can make this number as small
as I like I can still get really really
tiny numbers I still can't get so y
equals 0 there's no number you can put
into X think about this right you can
put a million into this you'll get a
really small number 1 over 2 million and
one that's small but it's not zero you
can put in a billion into that you'll
get 1 over 2 million one which is
smaller still but it's still not zero
you'll never ever get there right you
still have the same asset oh you have
the same range so I'm going to go y is
less than zero or y is greater than zero
okay in exactly the same way what does
this guy look like this graph if you go
ahead and you plot some points you'll
see it looks like this I put a little
filled circle on the airbed indicate i
can put an x equals 0 it actually works
just like the range sorry the domain is
X is greater than 0 horizontally what's
the range where can I go I can go
anywhere from y equals 0 and upwards you
see that so the range in this case is y
is greater than or equal to 0 okay I
don't leave off this one because
identical